LA Times columnist and a contributor to
ESPN's around the horn good morning bill
how are you good
yes Kendall a crisp lady what do you
think of it you know the NFL was so
strategic and everything that they do
the Commissioner comes out and says you
know what we're gonna maybe look at
preseason and maybe cut it in half here
what's the end game here do you think
with the Commissioner in the NFL
there's tryna make more money right
they're trying to get more money out of
the TV partners and tried with money
other sponsors I think it's crazy I
think you're right I don't know why the
players would agree to that I know
you're saying some of the young players
might but this is it how can the league
claim could care about the players help
and then add two more games to to more
serious games to this I think that
that's absurd a way especially with non
guaranteed contracts so yeah I think
it's a money grab but I don't see I hope
the players union is strong enough to
say no to this I can't imagine they
would say yes how do you think last
year's season by the Rams affected the
fan base or the potential for new fans
for the Rams in Los Angeles I think it I
think it helped I think the way it ended
didn't help very much and it was like a
lot of fans said yep see it I told you
so we should have been ran banned in the
first place but I think yeah I think
you'd gathered up some steam and some
momentum it's still a long way away I
mean is there still there's still the
third if not the fourth team in it
probably the fourth team in town and so
there's still you know it was weird to
see them in in a Super Bowl yes we still
got non headlined by the Dodgers Lakers
and USC football so I think it's slow
and I think once they've been moving the
new stadium in 2020 it'll probably pick
up and probably gain more traction but
it's still it helped but it's not there
yet all right let me get to the Lakers
here and you know I'm reading your
column it felt little doom and gloom ish
there that if you don't pick up a couple
of free agents does LeBron look around
and go wait a minute here what am i
doing as I want to try to win at least
one more championship here what do you
think is realistic if you're a Laker fan
and you're listening and what do you
what do you think is realistic that you
can tell them that happens this
offseason
well I don't know you know what nobody
knows because of all the upheaval and
turmoil nobody knows I think
realistically they you know I know the
Lakers believe that if they don't get if
they don't hit a homerun here LeBron is
gonna be good Ron's gonna check out and
whether that means he will ask out
whether they have to trade him or
whether he'll just just you know
emotionally detached from the team and
hit me the next two years long as years
of their lives they're not sure but
they're they're pretty convinced he's
check it out it's if they strike out so
I'm thinking they're thinking they need
to bring in a Kyrie which is which is
possible Kevin Durant which is not
possible quiet Leonard still possible I
think or Anthony Davis I think one of
those four names are pretty much about
the only thing I don't think Jimmy
Butler is gonna do it hmm
I don't think trading for Bradley Beal
is gonna do it I think one of those four
names is the only thing only sure bet
they can have and those are both those
are really swinging it low you know you
know low pitches it's a it's a it's a
really it's a tough ground for them
right now and I don't I don't know if
they could do it and I don't think Laker
fans aren't sure they can do it I don't
think anybody knows they could do it
bill but I'm curious about this then I
keep hearing people say well Kyrie could
end up with the Lakers I'm just looking
at this from a common sense perspective
of okay maybe he joins LeBron but also
doesn't he want the most money possible
doesn't he want to sign and trade if
you're Boston don't you want to do a
sign in trade so you get something in
return
and if you're Kyrie you're gonna be
selfish and want as much money as
possible is he leaving 30 40 50 million
dollars on the table just to play with
LeBron well we said we would Kyrie leave
an NBA championship team just to be his
old man he did that right so he's he's a
wild card we have no idea what he's
doing so I don't think you can say
anything about about him making any
predictions about what he's doing and I
think you know I think he realized on
his own
being a leader he's better being the
second guy and I think he realized that
and I think yeah that's why what that's
what makes a latest attracted to I think
he realized he had it pretty good with
LeBron and he could work at her and this
could work out here if he came out
this could work this would satisfy the
fans he was satisfied LeBron they keep
all their young players for a you know
portrayed balls per team ID that could
work Kyrie could work out here I think
that's their best that's our best option
that's their best hope
but thanks Iike why I can't see quite
coming there no I don't I just think his
personality right you know you know he
can go to Los Angeles but that doesn't
mean he's going to the trendy spots it
feels like you know he could go to you
know a drive-through restaurant and or
you know fast food he would be fun in
and out it's called but I also wonder
with you know then what do you do with
Lonzo ball if you bring in Kyrie you
know I would trade him I would trade him
for a draft for like a dress others talk
about about you know trading him to get
like a draft pick or something and get
the inner drive trade him right trade
him right now he's fragile
he's brittle he has a lot of baggage
with him and he hasn't he hasn't proved
he can play in the NBA if you ask me and
I think I care where you drafted him
remember he was magics guy you know
magic magic sky Magic's gone now I don't
I think the gloves are off on Lonzo ball
but yeah I don't think that you'd be
able to be working one second about him
you know the the magic thing and I spoke
publicly about it that if you're gonna
have him on ESPN and talked to him about
what happened there behind the scenes
then at least have the writer on your
own writer who wrote all of this about
magic I guess I still came away saying
you know there's no culpability with
magic with what happened with the Lakers
I just wanted him to say you know what I
made these mistakes here it felt like
everybody else made mistakes but Magic
Johnson what was your big or what is
your big takeaway from you know his exit
strategy very very disappointing very
disappointing there's no culpability
with him at all there is no
self-revelation with him he doesn't
understand how he comes across he says
he loves the Lakers and then he rips
them you know Google comes out in public
rips of a return and I realized
everything he said is true everything he
said was true you can't really say that
in house you know if you want to quit
you have to grab me by the shoulders
okay bill having a press conference
right now
I quit which is exactly what
but in the hallway there don't you tell
your owner first you know I just think
you were disappointing the way and I
think the shine is off you know his glow
out here I think people remember a lot
of people here never saw him play a lot
of kids never saw him play and they see
him only as a businessman and it's a
failed basketball executive and they
think he's just he comes across as being
selfish he's hurting at least hurting
the Lakers and I've I've written several
columns telling him to just zip it just
zip it just in fact I found us on the
show today I thought he said something
to me on the show cause he said
something else last night every day
you're waking up you say what's he
saying what's he doing now and you know
he's still by the way you know he's
still consulting with Jeannie she still
calls him four so that's amazing thing
about it he you know he walks out on him
and they still use his advice I
guarantee you I guarantee to make a big
creation signing this summer killed the
he'll take credit for it and he'll
probably deserve credit for it because
because he's still involved but I would
think Kobe would be my trump card here
my missing something on this bill if he
doesn't care Kobe wants nothing to do
with his mess he's moved on he wants
nothing to do and he has told people
close to me I want nothing my name out
of this I'm I'm you know busy winning
Academy Awards and Emmys and all that
stuff and I had no way know he's for the
minute I'm you know III spoke to Kobe
like two days after his retirement we
talked about some stuff and he's like
I'm done
I'm done with basketball I'm out of here
and he's really remained true he's more
interested in the WNBA right now with
his daughter you know daughters being
basketball players he is not yeah yeah
everybody thinks cool he's gonna come to
the rescue
he has no interest in rescuing anybody
but it went but himself yeah it just
feels like you know these these players
today they still have such great
admiration for Kobe that if you could
play that trump card and I would go to
that as often as I could instead of
Magic Johnson well the problem isn't you
know don't forget Kobe was involved when
he played in free agent you know and
trying to get the white hire and try and
get LaMarcus Aldridge you know and he
called him the room and he would yell at
these guys come to the Lakers you'll
never be me but you gotta brush your but
it may be Devin chance these guys walk
out of the room shaken and scared and
weak and they said we're not good at
please guys so I'm not so sure dad now
if you wanted to do that that's not
really a good idea I don't think but I
thought is he working out the younger
players I was told that that he does he
does help some of these younger players
well we have not seen that yes maybe in
this private we have not seen that okay
but he does you know he is he is you
know he's in he's he's he has I'll tell
you what his image here has risen in
remarkably of course full of them anyway
but since LeBron came they're like oh my
god you know even more so than ever
lamanna's know Kobe Kobe you know I'm
saying Kobe's mythology got even greater
last year like Kobe wouldn't do that
probably wouldn't have done that Kobe's
not that Syrian people don't like him
love him now but again the more beloved
he is the more he stays away yeah they
missed the playoffs the last six years
and five of those were with Kobe
involved somehow some way no but you
know this last year remember you know
remember Kobe last time we labeled the
playoffs he wore himself out so much he
tore his Achilles on the last day and
got him in there and carried him in
there LeBron wouldn't do that
no Brian couldn't do that wouldn't do
that and that drove Krantz crazy no fans
fans the last thing they remember him on
the court is a 60 point retirement game
I mean that was such a greatest ending
ever and so no no he's he's like Teflon
out here now people just absolutely
adore him and and and Vince that's
probably one of the reasons you don't
want to get back into it you realize
he's really beloved now he didn't want
to besmirch that by going in there and
scaring away some poor free agent again
but do you think that the honeymoon is
over from LeBron with Laker fans oh yeah
absolutely
oh it's way it's way over all fans in
fact if you ask me physical pull right
now I would say a lot of would say it's
okay to trade him and I've talked a
little people wondering what we're
saying think if we traded them they'd be
fine with it
if they got some bats something back and
got their that got their franchise back
got their kids back got their future
back that there Laker culture back if
they created him absolutely
I was there you know when Van Gundy I I
said look I I would really consider
trading him if I could get Anthony Davis
and I like if I can get ten
years younger eight years younger I can
I can build some players around this I
can get rid of the circus you know
feeling to this man I'd strongly
consider that bill oh I think if we're
sitting there June 15th and they have
nobody I think they've got a drug
they've got to do it and I don't know me
not sure so I says well who will take
them somebody's gonna take LeBron James
somebody will take them off their hands
they'll get the draft picks I would do
it in a heartbeat in an absolute
heartbeat ingest all the wood Van Gundy
said what a lot of LA had been thinking
is that is that and you know they've
been afraid to admit to themselves that
you know what this didn't work out get
out of it or all the students are better
so yeah I think that's an absolute
possibility do you think LeBron ends his
career as a Laker at this point no I
don't see that I just I don't see it I
don't see it working out this summer I
don't see it they have to really make a
big big hit and I just don't see that
but as with everything you could be
wrong just again you know remember
LeBron came here for LA he didn't cover
for the Lakers gimr for LA to live in LA
and if the basketball is going bad he'll
just go play basketball somewhere else
thank you Bill I appreciate you get you
that's great thank you that's bill flash
Kay LA Times columnist and contributor
to around the horn for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]